[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants rouges
elle est encombrante avalise nounours et
tu ne veut toujours pas me dire ce qu'il
ya dedans
nomos le mot patron c'est une surprise
et je n'ouvrirai cette valise que je
sais pas preneur et nicolas mon les
cheveux ma valise et bien mes petits
amis
il ne nous reste plus qu'à attendre que
nounours louvre et nous saurons enfin ce
qu'elle contient
[Musique]
bonsoir du color bosphore pas preneur
non je vous avais d'un voyageur un gros
voyage hors jeu nous affolons pas tenez
posé ma valise sur la tête
[Applaudissements]
c'est un hommage qui skie 6,1 à nos bas
c'est un monsieur qui n'arrête pas de
voyager mais celui-ci voyage avec sa
maison qui est une maison de la vanille
il porte même sa maison sur son dos
alors nous ne devinez pas qui c'est
c'est bien compliqué tant l'histoire
alors montre non fiction novel jeux
bretons je ne trouve pas plus j'ai dû
donner se tromper non non je ne trouve
pas non qu'est ce que j'ai fait de cette
hausse que tu es ma la noce pourquoi
rien la clé nos motos dont je suis beta
attention
j'ouvre la voilà qui est ce qu'un grand
pirate écorne sinon je t'ai est ce qu'un
beau tir raté comme la ville est une
chanson sur ce corps gras tu rates
accord du cola va chercher de la salade
verte pour notre nouvel avis est comme
[Musique]
la salade pour monsieur l'escargot ce
qu'il est content il en a de la chance
de voir sa maison sur son taux de mal
j'ai très pratique pour les voyages
allons petit escargot manger votre
salade effet tout au dos d'âne est cuit
petit escargot bonne nuit
nomade bonne nuit dehors
inouï comme ça dort jusqu'à 1 go
ils rentrent leur tête dans leur
coquille il ferme les yeux et il dans
[Musique]
exactement allons bonne nuit les petits
escargots pas ni hélas à tombo
bonne nuit les enfants n'oubliez pas de
faire votre toilette de bien vous laver
les dents embrasse bien fort aux parents
allez vite vous coucher il fait de beaux
rêves en rond bono
où
m